preso tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono vari generi oggi siamo su
file nights lights che sarebbe
quest'uomo quest'uomo che ha fatto del
big mac
il suo stile di vita è una roba allora
dovrebbe essere una specie di parodia
file night at freddy's solo che queste
una notte sola quindi one night with ma
veramente mi spiegate perchè c'è winnie
the pooh squartato sul tavolo ragazzi a
in flight i banchi ma [ __ ] sentite
cioè io posso mai ricevere le chiamate
da antibes ampi del cazzo di nome con
kalac rosa più bella ma va bene lo
stesso scaffale la vita ci guardate che
roba guardate la scimmia che guarda al
dotto è bellissimo cioè meglio questo
che fai nights freddy's direi secondo me
allora si può vedere buongiorno
lei è qui perché c'è una festa è che
festa sia non si sta divertendo non
perfetta c'è un tizio che sembra una
zolletta di zucchero con le braccia le
gambe però vabbè c'è questa che è una
telecamera scassata qua ci sono di
murray va questa musica ragazzo in
questa stessa scegliendo di allora
fatemi capire c'è sott.it dove cazzo
andato dove nel tirato un cazzotto ma
poverino chiuso è successo ma che si può
fare salve lei che fissa la telecamera
buongiorno scotti stava cagando non
volevo disturbare la zia c'è molto molto
simpatico
[ __ ] [ __ ] bastimento che cazzo è
successo ma come cosa protesta merda
perché ci sono delle uova sono occhi
nella padella bene fronti
non so se presente i big mac su per il
culo però ci penso io no ragazzi sono
morto lontana [ __ ] che botta è stato
pazzesco bene bello mi piace sul 1 f
figo
no ragazzi allora scusate mi na cosa
cazzo è successo perché c'è un cervello
perché c'è un elefante con una toppa sul
culo perché c'è un tostapane è perché
c'è un tizio che sembra una zolletta di
zona chi cazzo è quello ragazzi c'è un
nuovo c'è un nuovo con delle braccia
striminzite ma come cos'è sta roba mai
sentite ai fanti plant soletta dov'è
andato flanker dov'è dove dove e come
dove cazzo andato regali impossibile è
sparito io cosa devo fare qui ma sono
porte sentite cosa devo fare qual è il
mio scopo in questi domini
ma se in testa di merda ma di quelli che
mi gratifica un cartone ragazzi fatemi
capire che cosa devo fare in questo
gioco dove sta girando i comandanti fico
un cazzotto mi fate capire cosa allora
sentite stranzi cosa devo fare io nella
mia vita allora qua ci sono luci e qua
ci sono le porte a hama si chiude la
porta ai c'è la batteria che si scarica
in base a quanto tengo le porte chiuse
meraviglioso quindi io devo tenere le
porte chiuse le porte chiuse perfetto
ragazzi devo tenere le porte chiuse e se
te ne vai dai cazzo mi fai un piacere
club di grazie ok perfetto capito ho
capito come si gioca
il che è raro come evento che è bello
che seif l'ampia l'ascolta zio poi
leggermente denunciare per il fatto che
mi ha fatto prendere due infarti di fila
come non soranzo questo sta leggendo il
giornale successo ma vi rendete conto
cioè una roba allora ascolta dov'è
beauvais lurido pezzente di merda lo
sapevo dove è andato zoletto eccoli sono
in due sono in due e sono fermi ma
questo per far qualcosa o paga e basta
in questo caso e bastano intanto guarda
la telecamera perfetto ragazzi e
bellissimo a parti stiano a parte gli
scherzi è fatto meglio di phinet freddi
secondo me solo che cazzo dove sono
tutti perché hai colto giornale stronzo
lui no e l'altro non c'è perfetto
l'altro a destra sicura ecco cos'è da il
signor gentleman
lo so che lei un gentleman e non
spaventa le persone lo so che lei non
spaventa le persone [ __ ] vacca che
brutto che ti sei tolto dal cazzo
e allora siete stronzi però almeno uno
alla volta c'è un attimo
ok se ne sono andati se non perfetto e
bello che se ne vanno così
istantaneamente non lo vedi quando se ne
vanno di capirlo tu tu che cazzo fai qua
mi fissa da due ore alla sentito a cagà
pace tranquillo e non mi travasare i
maroni perché metti un inquietudine sto
cristiano che avete idea no no
madonna che ti consiglio un dentista zio
no anche bravo
si vabbè rega volete spuntar mi dal
pavimento non lo so ditemelo è perché
basta dirlo porca [ __ ]
sono le due di notte ancora la batteria
metà fantastico in file naked freddi
sapremo già finito la partita tre volte
meraviglioso dove flu aiuto non lo vedo
ragazzi quando un amico mio io mi
coprire il culetto perché ti stanno per
inglobare te lo voglio dire d'amico è
poi fai quello che vuoi
mi piaccio la tensione a mille ragazzino
[ __ ] vacca ascolta zio è finito la
carta igienica per quanto ho visto
mentre puliva il culo ed è meglio così
anzi gara sono contento ho l'ansia mi
hai vanhoutte merda
[Applauso]
dosa pezzo di stronzo di merda che ti
ammazzo la famiglia che brutto che sei
dove sono cadute le giuro che lo sapevo
avrei scommesso ma qualsiasi cosa che mi
avrebbe rotto il cazzo ma lo sapevo
prezzo di uno strano è il vero che ha
corso pure se mal a fan culo che hai
finito la carta igienica ma cosa vuoi da
me
cioè io non ho parole allora il toriale
una parodia di file night express ma è
peggio è anche peggio dichiara
bruttissima st scena non mi correva il
bello è che lui è passato da qua si è
fatto tutto sto cazzo di corridoio fino
arrivare qui e poi è arrivato dove sono
io ma [ __ ] allora sentite io non è
che sono tranquilla
allora ce l'hai la cartella e pulisciti
il culo e non rompere i [ __ ]
ok no no no allora tu devi morire tu
pure 77 te l'hanno beccato che sfiga
dobbiamo fare una gara di sguardi zio
no perché sei brutto la carta igienica
che pian piano di diminuisce
meraviglioso fermi fermi fermi perché
non si sta chiudendo la porta ragazzi
perché non mi si sta chiudendo la porta
rega ragazzi porca [ __ ] praga
[Applauso]
cito la famiglia in 13 modi diversi al
free to me di famiglia
ok ragazzi siamo in posizione stabile
c'è ai verona un cazzo 2 la tua fortuita
gli artigiani che riemergano a cagare
dove sono gli altri mortacci loro l'ho
fatta l'hai presa su ca su container
no no prima pulisciti può infine a
calarmi in attimo che amica è stato ri
chiaramente questo correva davanti a me
perché voleva la carta igienica come
sociale signor che cazzo ma come una
mamma [ __ ] preturo che non ho
capito dov'è finita la soletta di
zucchero è sparita adesso questa si vede
prima mons cos'è 41 ragazzi 4 di notte
questo sta rifinendo la carte già che
cosa hai mangiato ieri mi mortacci tua
pagare il caffè non puoi farti la scorta
di carta igienica invece di correre
sempre mio dio calmi
sta diventando sono le quattro ce la
posso fare c'è la posso fottutamente
fare solo 4 in o tre gare il bello che
non vedo questa telecamera di mortaio
dove lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso la
vita dove dove è andato l'altro per
tutti quanti a fare il party che se io
non capisci come il cazzo è questo sul
muro
no no no no no no cosa sta successi
cazzo est agente piazzi se uno sul muro
a caso ci penso che questo non ho idea
di chi sia ma c'è troppa gente che sta
facendo sta uscendo questa finito la
carta igienica questo esce dal muro
c'era uno rosso prima al posto di di
flauti dove cazzo siamo ragazzi
salve lei sa perché ha sbagliato strada
e ha sbagliato strada non ha sbagliato
dati stranzi di merda che succede è
morto ma cosa ma do chi cazzo è questo
no sentite ma [ __ ] ma dai
mica ci ho messo due orchi e che un
fatto soggiorno chrome gradonati tutti
faccio mangia la stessa roba che mangia
flam ti giuro che fa malissimo più che
ragazzi concluso qui episodio spero dia
video vi sia piaciuto a me personalmente
è piaciuto di più di file natel freddy's
non so perché ricordatevi la cosa c'è
una morale in tutto questo che dovete
tener presente se è finita la carta
igienica non cagate il cazzo afa vj
punto questa la morale mi one night
atlantis niente ragazzi se sapete come
finirlo magari ci provo fatemi sapere
che secondo voi qual è la tattica perché
non ho capito cosa è successo se il
video è piaciuto l'assenza il sottomento
mi piace anche la pace di facebook e
come nei video trovate la descrizione
posteriori si stima 10.000 euro prossimo
vito belle ragazze